learn how to build a beautiful and
responsive web portfolio with spel kit
and Tailwind CSS spel kit is a framework
for building web applications with spelt
providing tools for serers side
rendering routing and more Tailwind CSS
is a utility for CSS framework for
rapidly building custom user interfaces
without writing custom CSS when combined
spelt kit and Tailwind CSS offer
developers a seamless experience
enabling the creation of Highly inter
active web applications with a clean
responsive design James MacArthur
created this course he is a fullstack
developer and course creator web
portfolios who needs them well actually
a lot of people do for example you might
be trying to get a tech job or perhaps
you want to have an Internet space where
you can show all of your portfolio work
perhaps even you are looking for a
coding project and just want an internet
presence to demonstrate your flare and
capability all of these are brilliant
reason to have your own internet
portfolio live and hosted on the
internet we're going to be coding the
whole thing from scratch in spelit and
Tailwind brilliant tutorial step by step
and at the very end we will deploy it so
it's live on the internet and you can
send it to your mom so without further
Ado if you enjoyed the video don't
forget to like And subscribe thank you
so much for watching and let's dive into
the code so demo of the web portfolio
let's take a look here we have Samuel
Oak AKA fake small James and this is our
landing page we've got some nice get
InTouch buttons we've got a couple
little navigation links up the top it's
all very catchy as you can see in the
background we have this cool particle
animation effect which just makes us
seem all the more deep and interesting
if we scroll down a bit or use these
navigation links we get some uh project
displays and we can use the go-to
buttons to actually click on them if you
wanted you could add an a video after
that we've got a bit about me it's just
uh some information so that they can
learn more about you looks super
aesthetic finally we've got a table
because everyone needs a good table this
one weighs up all of the candidates if
you're applying for jobs and shows that
you are clearly the best candidate in
the field finally why not invest and
then at the very bottom we have some
little contact me uh links in the footer
of our document so it just looks uh very
neat and tidy not too complicated and
obviously the whole thing is also
extremely responsive super critical as
well so with the demo out of the way
let's go ahead and get started with our
project so for that we're going to come
over to the Tailwind CSS and spel kit
and nit project documentation which will
be linked in the description down below
and we at the same time going to open up
a terminal in the directory of our
choosing and we are going to start
typing in these commands so that's going
to be
npm create spelt at latest and we're
going to give our project name which is
going to be amazingly awesome portfolio
let's hit enter on that and that is
going to start initializing our project
for now we're just going to select a
skeleton project we are not going to do
any type checking we will add es lint
for code linting and now we can go ahead
and open up my amazing
inly awesome
portfolio inside of a code editor so I'm
using visual studio code but you can use
any code editor of your choice and we
can scroll down just here and we can uh
inside of our Visual Studio code open up
another terminal that's just going to be
in the directory of our new project
going to paste these mpm install
commands in once that one's done we're
going to do npx tail when CSS and n-p
and then we're just going to come over
to our spelt doc config and copy this
stuff across uh just displace everything
that's currently there and likewise with
the Tailwind doc config we'll do exactly
the same down to the last two steps
we're going to have to come into our
source directory inside of here we going
to create a new file called app.
CSS we can go ahead and copy in these
base directives and likewise we can come
inside of the routes and create a plus
layout. spelt where the plus layout is a
reserved spelt component name that's
going to wrap our entire project and we
can just go ahead and import that
app.css in here and as I said before
this slot is going to render out
everything inside of the plus page.
spelt which is another reserved spelt
component name so finally we're good to
boot up our project we can come down
here and type impim run div that will
open it up on Local Host
5173 we can go there hit enter and here
we see our project zoomed out way too
much just to test that everything is
working I'm going to type class text
green 400 we see that update and we know
that it is working so that is step one
complete we have now configured T and
CSS inside of our news felt kit project
so just before we dive in let's take a
look at the file directory that we are
working with the core folders that we're
going to be looking at inside of this
directory is the source and possibly the
static directories everything else here
is by majority just configuration files
obviously if you wanted you could make a
cool little readme.md for the project
not going to be touching the node
modules either and inside of the source
directory here we have a lib folder
where we can have some JavaScript if we
wanted or anything that we wanted to
import not going to be relevant for this
particular tutorial routes is is our
route-based navigation system so the
home route or the base level route route
is just going to be this page dovel
which gets rendered inside of this
layout dovel these two files get
rendered within our app. HTML just in
this particular uh tag right here and
obviously we have our app.css which we
may touch later on Just for some custom
Styles if you wanted to update the Fab
icon just here that would be this
particular
file and the other thing to know is that
in here we obviously have the head tag
where we can add some header elements or
you can use the Customs felt head tag uh
which we may or may not do later on in
this video so the first place we're
actually going to start is in this app.
HTML file right here and that is going
to be with
some Google fonts and font awesome icons
so just initializing and configuring
them so we're going to come over to
Google font FS nice and easy links for
everything will once again be in the
description down below and we are going
to look for Poppins is the font that we
are going to be using in this project
and we are going to add all of the
non-italicized fonts to our little
selection view the font families just
here uh so here we have all of the
Poppins fonts I guess you could take the
italic ones that you want and down here
you're going to see a large link tag
with a copy at the bottom we're going to
copy that directly into our head
underneath the the head of our document
the head tags underneath the meta one
just there paste that
in nice and easy and then we're also
going to come over to the font awesome
CDN page uh Link in the description and
we're going to copy this top link tag
right here as well paste that just at
top the other one and now we have
imported our fonts and we have have
enabled the use of font awesome icons in
our project in addition to that we are
going to come into the body tag of our
app. HTML just here and we are going to
give this a class and this is just going
to have a background of slate 950 a text
of white and a relative tag as for this
div inside the body tag we're going to
give this a class as well this is going
to be relative and we're going to give
this a zed index of a custom amount of
one which is why we wrap it inside of
the square parentheses save that and we
see our Styles update as we would expect
them to Easy Breezy Covergirl the next
thing we're actually going to do is
configure the particle JS that we saw in
the background just here to do that
we're going to come over to a package
called particle
JS right here a lightweight JavaScript
library and we are going to look for the
CD in
package just here so we can come over to
the particle JS CDN package we're going
to copy this Min one and likewise with
the other tags we're just going to paste
this up the top right here and now we
are going to get this up and running
inside of our document by creating a div
that has a class of absolute Min height
screen top of Z left of Zer a width of
full a zed index of a custom amount of
-1 and finally an opacity of 70 so that
it doesn't overwhelm
everything inside of this we're going to
have a div and this has a class uh of
absolute and inser zero and we're going
to give this div an ID of particles this
has to be spelled correctly particles
DJs and this is going to be selected by
the particle uh library that we just
added so we're going to add a script
underneath that div and call
particle
JS particles
js. load and we're going to pass in that
ID so particles
DJs and we're also going to load in an
assets file so that's going to be/
assets SLP
particles.
Json after that we're going to pass in a
call back function so that's going to be
a function we're going to open up that
function and in here we're just going to
say
console.log
callback
particles.js config
loaded uh make sure we close that just
there so that's going to load and break
because we do not have that asset file
in there at the moment but that is
absolutely fine we can do that in a
minute the place that we are going to
come across that asset file is if we go
back to the original particle JS website
here you can create your own custom one
so you can you know interact with the
background color make it however you
want uh but I already have one that's
pre-existing you can download it from
the GitHub repository that is linked in
the description down below and so we're
just going to come into our directory
here inside of static we're going to
create a new folder called assets and
that is going to have a
particles. Json file paste that all in
and now if we refresh the page we would
have expected that particle JS file to
load however it did not and that's
because the script tag that we copied
from earlier is not going to cut the
mustard so make sure you copy the script
tag from the GitHub repository also it's
just the one specifically for the
particle js on line six and just like
that we can see we have our uh particles
in the background uh super neat little
effect that just makes your portfolios
look even Tech here so that pretty much
ends our start in the app. HTML file the
next one we're going to come over to is
the app.css and in here what we are
going to do is start off by selecting
the HTML of our document and we are
going to give this a scroll behavior of
smooth after that we're going to select
everything in our entire page and give
that a font family of Roboto and a
backup of sans serif now you might say
James we don't have the robot Auto font
family and you would be absolutely
correct because I forgot to add it so we
can quickly resolve that by coming back
into Google fonts throwing in all of
these Styles above and beyond the ones
that we have already added uh from the
Poppins Library quickly toss all them in
the mix and just copy that link tag once
more and replace the prior one that was
already inside of our app. HTML just
here so just these
ones
nice and quick and easy and that font
will update inside of our document after
changing everything to robotto we're
going to select the H1 H2 and H3 tags
and we're going to give them a font
family of you guested Poppins and
likewise a backup of sans serif and in
addition to selecting the actual tags
we're also just going to create a class
that's called Poppins which is also
going to apply the Poppins font family
so that's going to do for this document
for now so we can close out a couple of
these config files and the next thing we
can do is come into our source directory
and create a new folder called
components and this is going to have the
core components of our document which is
going to be a footer do spelt we'll have
a header do spelt we're going to have a
main do
spelt and we're also going to have a
step dots felt so ensuring that the
component name is is capitalized and we
have the dots felt at the end of the
component with that we can come into the
main of our document and we can add a
script and we can also just call the
main component render that out like we
have here and import
main from dot do/ components
SL main.
spelt so it's going to import that
component just there we can check that
that's working by typing but that is not
going to work because this is actually
meant to go inside of this uh page
component just here so we're going
to render out the main component and
then in here we can type James that
comes up on the screen as we would
expect so that component is working
nicely so yeah just copying everything
that we previously had in main into this
page.
layout so that's our components working
the next one we're going to come into is
the layout and this one has a little bit
more going on we're going to start off
with a div and this is going to have a
class of
relative Flex Flex column a Max width of
1,400
pixels uh we use square brackets cuz
that's a custom amount an MX of Auto a
width of full text small uh until we
reach the small break point and then the
text is going to be the base
size and finally Min height of screen as
well uh I'm actually going to not do so
much of the styling and start off just
doing the HTML first and we can come
back and do the styling later but other
than that we're going to have a div just
in here we'll come back and do the class
shortly this div is going to contain a
button that has an up Arrow so that is
going to be an font aw some icon so we
can call icon class fa a solid fa Arrow
up equally you could look at the font
awesome site and just copy that directly
now this little icon right here is going
to show up in the you can't see the
bottom of our screen so there it is this
little icon we're going to use that for
that effect right there but more on that
later after our button we're going to
have our header component which is going
to get imported up the top then we are
going to have our slot in the middle
which is going to be everything inside
of the page which is the main of our
document and then at the bottom we can
have our footer component which we will
also import and then finally down the
bottom of our document we're going to
have a special velt component it's going
to be spelled window and we're going to
bind the scroll y height set that equal
to a variable Y which we are going to
Define shortly and we're also going to
bind the inner
height and we're going to bind the inner
width super simple and easy now if we
come up the top we can say let inner
width or inner height equals Zer and we
can say let inner height H sorry width
equal Z also and while we're up here we
we Define a function that is go top uh
and this is just going to say
document.body do scroll into view and
that will scroll us to the top of our
page so now that we've done all of the
componentry inside of our plus layout we
may as well add in the Styles so for
this div right here which contains our
back to top button we're going to wrap
our classes string inside of an object
so that we can make it a bit more
customized and give it a a position of
fixed bottom Z width full duration
200 Flex padding of 10 and a z of a
custom number 10 we're going to make
sure we leave a space at the end of that
string and then add a plus and the
circular braces and in here we're going
to run a logic check that just says Y is
greater than zero this just means that
we have scrolled away from from the top
of the page and then we're going to say
if yes we're going to have a string and
if no then we're going to have a
different string so this is just a
oneline if else check using the question
mark this is the true statement this is
the false statement if
the Y is greater than zero we're going
to set the opacity to full we're going
to set pointer events to Auto and
otherwise we're going to say
pointer events none and we're going to
set the
opacity to
zero so if we come into our page we can
see that something is severely wrong and
that's because down here we have to make
sure we close this little spout
window uh and just like that it's all
working the next component we're going
to style is our header component now in
here what we're going to do is we're
going to say EXP let Y and that all
needs to be inside of a script tag don't
let me forget to do that so we're going
to add
the script tag just here we're going to
say export let y this is how we pass
props between components so this is
essentially us receiving the prop if it
was just a variable defined inside of
this component we wouldn't need the
export and inside of our layout we just
want to make sure to our header that we
actually pass down y so we're going to
say Y is equal to Y and while we're
actually back in here I forgot to finish
one or two other things we're just going
to quickly add an onclick event to this
button that is inside of our layout uh
and that's just going to say go top and
finally we're going to add a class to
the very same button and just say margin
left of Auto which is ml Auto rounded
full background slate 900 text Violet
400 padding x 3 until we hit the small
break point at which point we set the
padding X to four a hover of background
slate 800 cursor pointer uh display of
grid Place
items Center and an aspect Square should
do us pretty well so yeah let's go ahead
and close that layout component and come
back into our header where we have just
or just received that prop the y prop
after that we're going to define a
header component inside of our header we
have an H1 tag uh inside of the H1 we're
going to have a bold this is going to be
your name so I'm going with Samuel and
then outside of the Bold we're going to
have the secondary name which is going
to be Oak after the H1 we're going to
have a div that has a class uh that we
will Define shortly and in here we're
going to map out some items using the
spel kit or spel each where we say # tag
each inside of the curly parentheses we
pass in an array which is tabs and we
say each individual item is going to be
referred to as Tab and we're also going
to take the index inside of here we're
going to register out an anchor tag and
inside the anchor tag we're going to
have a paragraph that just has the tab.
name with that we should probably come
into our script and just uh Define tabs
so that's going to be let tabs equal to
the square brackets uh so an array and
inside of our array we're going to have
a series of objects uh each object will
have a name so the first one for example
will be projects and then the link is
going to be # projects which will be the
ID of that section as we Define shortly
I'm going to duplicate that three times
and just uh set the second one to about
uh
me and that's just going to have a link
of about or an ID of about and then
finally we're going to have blog and I'm
going to delete this last one uh because
it's not entirely necessary if you have
a Blog then that is awesome and in here
we also have to make sure we actually
add a key for that particular value so
that that is Happy uh you'll notice in
this portfolio just here if you click
blog we
get which possibly isn't the effect
you're looking to have for any
prospective employers so if you have a
Blog then obviously feel free to add
that one in so now we can see each of
the items showing up on the screen just
there just as we would want we can go
ahead and start styling everything in
this component we're going to start off
with the
uh class on the header now like in our
previous component we're going to wrap
that inside of wrap the string inside of
a curly parenthesis cuz it's going to
have some Dynamic classes and that's
going to be sticky we're going to give
it a zed index of 10 a top of zero a
duration of 200 a padding X of six Flex
items Center justify everything
between we're going to give it a border
b a border
solid and then after all of that we're
going to finish that with a space in the
end of that string and then we're going
to have plus circular
parentheses and in here once again we're
going to say y greater than Z if it's
true we're going to have one class uh
appended if not another set so if it is
true we're going to say padding y of
four background slate 950 and Border
Violet 950 and if it's false we're going
to say padding y of six background
transparent and Border
transparent and we'll see what that does
shortly but essentially what it means is
that as we uh scroll when we scroll away
from the header then it's just going to
make the background opaque and we're
going to get a border bottom showing up
so that will look nice after that we
have our H1 this is going to have a
class of font
medium uh the Bold tag is going to have
a class of font bold and we're going to
set that to Poppins and then after we've
styled the H1 we're going to select the
div and just say small Flex items Center
gap for an otherwise headen so the
default dis will be hidden on a small
screen and then when we get to a booger
screen we're going to have a display of
flex uh so we can see that coming in now
after that we're going to style the ank
tags this is going to have a class of
duration 200 hover text Violet 400 and
we also have to make sure that we add
the href equal
to uh tab. link as we defined above so
that will work for our navigations we
can see if that's working it is indeed
very
nice and then finally what we're going
to have is a another button although
this is technically going to be an
anchor tag this is going to have a class
of blue shadow which we will Define
shortly a custom class after that we're
going to say relative overflow heading
px5 padding y of two group rounded full
background white text SL PL 950 inside
of here we're going to have a div that
has a class of absolute top zero right
full width full height full background
Violet 400 an opacity of 20 we also
going to say group
hover uh semicolon and we're going to
translate that element X full a z of Z
and a duration of
200 after this element we're going to
have an H4 this is going to say get in
touch and we'll just have to give this
one a class of relative and a zed of n
for this whole anchor tag we're going to
have an hre equal to whatever social
media uh platform you want them to get
in touch with you so that could be
linked in uh copy that link and paste it
in there and we're also going to set the
target toore blank and now we can see
the effect that this has that little
pseudo effect it just uh we get that
hover which is quite nice
so that is our header done the next
component is going to be the main
component now inside of our main
component we're going to start off by
opening up a script just as we have here
and then after that you guessed it we
have a main component or main tag we can
go ahead and open that up and uh after
that we're going to have a section which
we will give an
ID equal to intro
page and for the main we're going to
give this a class of flex Flex column
and a flex of one so that it occupies as
much space as it can uh and we're also
going to give that page a padding of
four now for the section we have here
essentially we're going to split up each
part of the main in sections so the
first section second section third
section so that would be the blog and
the you know projects and about me uh
and that's what the ideas are for to
scroll us to each individual section as
you will see shortly so our first
section is going to have a display of
grid grid calls one until a large break
point at which point we will upgrade to
a grid calls 2 we're going to give it a
gap of 10 a padding yre of eight and a
small padding yre of 14 uh when we go
above that small break
point following that we're going to have
a div that has a class of flex Flex
column on a large display or more we're
going to justify everything Center we're
going to put the text Center until we
get to the large display and then we're
going to say text left we're going to
put a gap of six until we get to a
medium screen and then upgrade to a gap
of eight and then on the large
breakpoint we're going to go to the Gap
of 10 inside of here we are going to
have an H2 tag this is going to have a
class of font semi bold text
4XL uh until we get to the small screen
then it's going to be text 5 XL and then
on a medium screen it's going to be text
6 XL so nice and large and this is going
to say hi I'm uh span tag
class Poppins text Violet 400 this is
going to be for a pretty uh little
Violet section this is going to say
Samuel or whatever your name might be
after that we can continue
Oak going to insert a breakpoint in the
text and then we're going to say full
stack and then we're going to have that
same span once
again just there and this is going to
say
developer and if we save that we can see
exactly how those two spans work right
there I think that looks pretty nifty
after that div we can have a paragraph
tag and this is going to have a class of
text base small text large uh and medium
text extra large so always going up and
this can say my uh same span class text
Violet
favorite
tech includes
JavaScript uh specifically
nextjs or obviously you would make this
custom to yourself or spelt kit as you
probably
noticed tail
wind CSS no surprise there
nodejs plus
Express JS and
postgress
SQL or Firebase SL fire store
exclamation and then we have our neat
little text showing up
and after that we are going to finish it
off with a button it's going to be a
very similar button to what we have in
our header and that's just going to be
the same anchor tag as before we're
going to have a class of blue shadow MX
Auto large screen or more is going to be
Mr Auto so margin right Auto we're going
to say text is the base size until we
get to the small screen then it's going
to be a text of large and then on the
medium screen we're going to go for a
text extra large we're going to give it
the font family Poppins relative display
overflow heading padding X of six
padding y of three uh we'll add a group
rounded full background white and a text
slate
950 after that exactly the same as we
did in our header we can copy that div
that's that little background div
in and we can actually also just copy
this H4 tag uh once again into just
after that div right there and what we
can do after this one though is we're
going to use the HTML Arrow so that's
the Ampersand R A RR Roar and now we get
the uh little amband right
there and just like that we have a cool
link we're also going to have the cursor
pointer
style added to that and in here just
like you did uh in the header we're
going to add the hre or the link to your
social media profile or wherever you
want them to get in touch and a Target
equals blank once again so that is 1
half of our grid display done then we're
going to have the second half which is
going to be a div that has a class of
relative Shadow 2XL an extra big Shadow
and then a grid and a place items
Center
now in here we're going to have an image
tag and this is going to be an image of
you're choosing whatever you like we're
going to access this image from images
SL profile.png or whatever it is that
you saved it as and that should actually
be Source equals uh equally we'll have
to add the alt which is just going to be
uh profile image and finally we're going
to add a class which is just object
cover a z index of a custom amount of
two and we're going to set the maximum
height equal to 70% of the view
height now this image doesn't currently
exist for me but I'm just going to paste
it in there going to create the file
it's going to be
images uh reveal in finder paste that in
and now if we open that up that is right
there and if I save this we get the
image showing up on the screen Happy
Days the only thing that is being a bit
mischievous here is uh this and that's
just because our button should be
wrapped inside of the div inside of our
header dot spelt uh and that's going to
make it match the replica equally you
could actually have it outside if you
prefer the button to display on the
smaller Mobile screen uh that would be
totally viable also so you know what
maybe we actually do just leave it
outside then the get touch just is
always
there I actually prefer it like that so
that is the first uh part of our main
component complete on to the second so
that's going to require a new section
and who can guess what this section is
going to have an idea of well it's going
to be from the links above it's going to
be projects
uh so we can go ahead and enter that
I'll make some space in here and now we
can give this a class of padding y of 20
on a large screen or Burger we can say
padding y of 32 Flex Flex column and a
gap of
24 inside of this section we have a div
that has a class of flex Flex column a
gap of to and a text of Center this is
going to be the header essentially for
this section which is why inside of that
we have an H6 that says a few of my
creative Endeavors full stop this H6 is
going to have a class of text
large small screen or larger text extra
large and on a medium or bigger screen
we're going to say text to extra large
uh noting that large should be LG not
large large underneath that we're going
to have an H3 this is going to be the
actual title uh and this is going to say
curious to span class
Poppins text Violet 400 as we' have seen
C after that we can continue with my
work question mark the H3 is going to
have a class of font semi bold text 3
extra large small text 4 extra large
medium text 5 extra large and then
underneath that we can have an anchor
which is going to have an hre this is
going to be the watch the video button
or you can just rck roll them like I
have the Rick Roll link is actually
going to be used in this project so if
you want that copy that from the GitHub
repo directly we're going to want to
make sure that this one has a Target
equals unor blank to open up a new tab
and this is going to have a class of
margin X Auto padding X4 padding Y2
rounded medium
border border solid border white a
display of flex item Center gap of two
minus margin
bottom four unless we are on a small
screen in which case it's going to be
minus bottom um minus margin bottom zero
uh and then we're going to set the minus
margin top is uh 10 so it's essentially
just setting a negative value
on Hover we're going to set the border
to being a violet 700 color and we're
just going to give the whole thing a
duration of
200 and in here we're going to have an
icon that has uh the
class fa a
regular uh and then fa a circle dplay
once again you can copy these uh code
them straight in or copy them from the
font awesome page and after the icon
we're going to have a paragraph tag that
that just says watch the video so we
should be able to see this pop up down
here there we have our margin top being
super weird talk about misbehaving uh
and that is because it is supposed to
come after the div not be within the div
so just fixing that we get our little
watch and we can also use our little
scroll to the top button uh which is
super nice and neat beneath all that but
still within the section we're going to
open up a dish
that has a class of grid grid calls one
until we hit a large screen at which
point we're going to set it to grid
calls 3 so that'll be three columns
we're going to have a gap of 12 until we
get to the large screen and then we're
going to have a gap of 10
downsizing in here we're going to use
the step component that we have created
and we're going to have three of them so
we're going to call
step uh and we're going to duplicate it
three times but before we do we want to
make sure that they have an opening and
closing tag because that is going to be
important for
later and in here we're just going to
pass down a prop known as step and we're
going to set that equal to steps which
is an array that we haven't yet defined
with the index which is going to be the
number or the uh sequence the ordered
sequence of which it is so it's going to
be 0 1
2 now as for what goes into step we're
going to have to come up to our script
and Define uh
steps so that's is going to be an array
and it's going to be an array of objects
where each object is going to have a
name field and an icon
field uh we're going to have three of
these the first one is going to be the
small James store or whatever your
project is and we're just going to copy
in the class name for the icon of your
choosing so this is going to be fa cart
shopping let's just go ahead and take a
look at some of the other icons though
so we can come over to font
awesome.com links in the description and
we can head over to their icons type in
banana I don't know if we oh look they
have bananas just not in the free
package we want to make sure that we're
using the free icons as much as we
can but you could have just about
anything you know here's all the free
icons so you could want one for Docker
for example and you can just copy the
class string not the whole tag so that
is all very
straightforward our second step is going
to be ultimate
todos uh this is going to have an icon
of fa solid fa list check and then the
last one is going to have an icon of
fa solid fa diagram
project and and a name of Pokedex which
if you're not familiar is what Samuel
Oak originally came up with he is the
Pokémon Professor that sends Ash Ketchum
on his mission so here we have the
Pokedex now I should also note that
these are project tutorials that I'm
going to be creating soon so if you want
the ultimate portfolio full of projects
that are going to get you a job just
like these then like and subscribe and
stay tuned for those to
come anyway now we have the steps we can
start on our step component obviously we
are passing down the step as a prop so
we're going to have to receive it inside
of the script tag so we can say export
let step that will give us access to the
step in this component and then we're
going to have an anchor tag it's going
to have an H rff equal to curly braces
that's going to be the step. the href
which is the link to the project we're
going to make make sure that anyone who
clicks on this is going to get opened up
in a new tab so perhaps it takes it uh
the user to the GitHub page for the
project or all the code or perhaps to a
live deployed version of the project and
after that we're going to give it a
class of padding for uh small breakpoint
padding six medium breakpoint padding 8
Flex Flex column gap for rounded
large border border solid border Violet
700 text Center group cursor pointer
hover border Violet 400 and finally a
duration of 200 inside of this we're
going to have a div that has a class of
background slate 950 grid Place items
Center a padding X of four a text of
five extra large medium
Tex Tex 6 extra large uh we're going to
set a negative margin top of 10 on the
small breakpoint it's going to be
negative margin top of 12 medium
breakpoint negative margin top of 14 and
large is going to be negative margin top
of 16 margin X of Auto and a duration of
200 inside here we're going to have the
icon with the class that is the step do
icon uh just like that so we can use the
curly parenthesis to set that after that
div we're going to have an
H3 uh that is going to be the step dot
name also I should just clarify that
this whole class here is to essentially
create the effect that we see just here
where it blocks out the purple line and
creates the space and the negative
margin top just drags the whole thing up
so it overlaps the the border of the
contain
container uh but back to the H3 we can
set a class of font medium text extra
large small text 2 XL and finally medium
text 3
XL uh after that we're going to Rend out
the slot which is essentially going to
be the children components which is
anything wrapped within the opening and
closing tags of the
component rendered out inside the main
dos felt and then finally we can have a
div that has a class of flex One Flex
justify
between gap of four and items end and
inside of here we can have a div that
has a class of margin left Auto cursor
pointer on Hover we're going to have a
text of slate
950 a duration of 200 relative and then
we're going to add in some pseudo
effects so we're going to say after
we're going to use the after pseudo
effect and give that a position of
absolute we're going to say after top of
zero we're going to say after height of
zero after right full after width full
after height full after
duration
200 uh and then this one's even more
complicated it's going to be on the
hover we're going to set the after equal
to translate X of full finally set the
after to a zed index of
-1 and an overflow of
headen now inside of here we can have a
p that has a class of relative and a z
of four and this can say go to and then
we can have the Ampersand raar for the
right arrow and that will show up with a
beautiful go-to just like that now one
thing that I notice is that the after
should also have a background of white
so we're just going to add that in after
background white I think I forgot
that and then we can set the Z to1 again
and now we just get this nice little
link hover effect as they uh click on it
technically they can click anyway but it
just makes people feel better and it's
more obvious if you actually give them a
go-to
link so now that we have defined that
component we can come back into the main
SE of our document and we can just add
in the children content to the step
components and that is going to be a
paragraph tag that says small James
store is a
merchandising store created
with then we're going to throw in a
strong tag with a class of text Violet
400 and we're going to have some tech so
it's going to be nextjs Commerce JS
stripe and nodejs plus expressjs my
goodness doesn't that sound like a good
text stack you should definitely watch
that video when it comes
out uh after that we're going to say
commerce. JS is a product content
management system and stripe is used for
all
transaction handling so that is our
first one we're actually going to copy
and paste that inside the rest of them
and then we're going to say for the
second
one ultimate todos is a full stack uh
and this is also going to be
nextjs uh no JS plus
Express uh and Fir store and fire I
guess it is Firebase uh crud application
application that allows a user to login
manage a
tidy not tiny and efficacious there's a
good word to-do list and persist this
information across
devices so that's the second one after
we've done that we can get rid of all of
the content between there and the full
stop and now we can do the very last one
which is going to just
say the PO
keex is a we're going to use the strong
tag with a class of text Violet
400 and in here it's going to
say
spelt kit and
Tailwind
CSS uh then we're going to jump outside
of the strong tag uh web
application comma hosted
on uh and then we'll do another strong
tag just as we have before hosted on
netlify uh and then we can
say that consumes and caches the then
we're going to have another strong tag
pokeymon
API to dis playay all
Pokémon
information got to catch them
all and then we can get rid of all the
remaining text just
there and that's going to do it for our
three uh items just
here and that's also going to do it for
this section so now we can create the
last section that comes above our
footer and this one is going to have an
ID equal to about so that when we click
the about keyword which is up the top it
will take us down to this section also
note that this should not be in the
middle uh but we can fix that very
easily just by
saying if we come into the
header we'll set this to an ml autoflex
one let's actually just do ml Auto and
we're also going to need a PR of
four uh so that's just going to push
them over there and keep that button for
us anyway back to the main component so
we can close that come down here we've
got our last section which is the about
we're going to give it a class of
padding y of 20 but we're going to
separately set the padding top to 10
then on a large break point we're going
to set the padding top to
16 and additionally on another large
break point we're going to set the
padding y 23 2 we're going to give it a
flex Flex column and a gap of 16 until
the small break point where we'll have a
gap of 20 and then the medium break
point where we're going to have a gap of
24 and finally a position of
relative inside of here we're going to
have a div this one is going to have a
largish class so bear with me this one
is going to be a flex Flex
column a gap of two text Center
relative
uh we're going to say before so we're
going to use the pseudo before element
we're going to give the pseudo before a
position of relative we're going to go
before top of zero before left of zero
before is going to have a width of 2/3
before is going to have a height of
1.5 before is going to have a background
of violet
700 uh and if we save
that we can see we get this line here so
that's perfect and now what we're going
to do is we're going to copy all the
before
Styles uh so we'll copy them and then
we'll paste
them just
afterwards and we're also going to
select all the pasted
befores and we're going to change them
to Afters so we're going to have two
separate pseudo
elements and we're also going to have to
change the left for a right and a top
for a
bottom and then we're going to change
the well actually that's pretty much it
so now we can just come in here and we
can add the actual elements so this is
going to have an
H6 that says want to know more question
mark tant izing I'm sure they absolutely
do we're going to give this a class of
text large until we get to the small
break point where it's going to be text
extra large and then the medium is going
to be text two extra large uh so we'll
save that there's our want to know more
for some reason our bottom one isn't
moving over so our before is left zero
our after should be right of zero not
sure what is causing that but we can
come back and fix that in a minute after
that we're going to have an H3 and this
is going to say uh a bit then we're
going to have our classic span that has
a class of Poppins text
3XL sorry that's actually just text
Violet
400 and inside of here we're going to
say about cuz this is the about section
and then we can finish that off with a
me dot so there we have a bit about me
this h H3 is going to need some Styles
so that's going to have a font semi bold
text 3XL until the small break point
where we're going to bump it up to a
text 4 extra 4 extra large and then
finally on the medium a
text 5 XL so now we have that header and
for some reason we have that misbehaving
div so what I'm going to do is I figured
out exactly what it is this after right
here and this before
both need to have a position of
absolute uh so that fixes that perfectly
I am just a
muppet but the one thing we're going to
have to add is a padding y of four and
then now we have the desired effect not
that you can even see it but there it is
just
there so that's that section looking
nice and tidy underneath this div we're
going to have a paragraph that has a
class of MX Auto
Poppins font semi bold text large small
text extra large medium text 2 XL and
this is going to say I am dot dot dot
with spaces between the
dots and then under here we're going to
have a
div that has a class of flex Flex call
Gap of 20 with full MX Auto and a
maximum width of a custom amount so we
use the square brackets that's going to
be 800
pixels in here we're going to use the
each which is going to map over all of
our benefits and we can extract each
individual benefit as a benefit and
we're also going to take the index and
then we can close the each and in here
we're going to have a div that has a
class of flex gap of six until we get to
small and then we're going to have a gap
of eight now for for this we're actually
going to need to Define some benefits so
we're going to come up to the top to our
script and say let benefits equal to an
array where each index is going to be an
uh
object and so in here we're going to
have a name field and we're going to
have a description
field uh so let's just duplicate that
three times and for the first one I'm
going to say a self-taught developer
uh for the second one I'm going to say a
product design and ux
fanatic and then for the last one I'm
going to say an excellent
Communicator can't neglect the soft
skills and then I'm quickly going to
fill out the descriptions I'm actually
just going to copy and paste them uh I'd
recommend writing stuff that you
personally resonate with but if you want
to use this as a template then the code
is in the GitHub if you just want to
copy and paste that
across so there are our benefits added
uh it looks like somewhere in here we
have to
escape uh an exclamation point but
that's all good and so now back down to
this div we can open that up and in here
we are going to start off with a
paragraph tag that has a class of
Poppins text 4 extra large small
breakpoint text 5 extra large medium
breakpoint text six extra large uh it's
going to be a text slate 500 so it's not
very uh stand itish and we're going to
give it a font of semi
bold and this is actually going to have
the index + one so we're going to use
the curly parentheses to render out a
JavaScript uh value and if we save that
here we can see we get the 1 two 3
showing up
and then after this paragraph we're
going to have a
div that has a class of uh that should
say div not ID div that has a class of
flex Flex
column uh a gap of six until we get to
the small breakpoint then we're going to
have a gap of eight so all the gaps are
equivalent and in here we can have an H3
that has a class of text 2 extra large
small breakpoint text three extra large
probably getting the vibe for this until
I say on a medium we're going to go text
5 XL so we're going to jump up
one that's going to have the uh the
benefit. name and then underneath that
we're going to have a paragraph tag that
has the benefit. description and that's
just going to be as you would expect and
so now we have the uh section showing up
looks like you're seeing some artwork in
a
museum
looks very nice and tidy and so if we
take a look at the actual website we can
scroll down to the bottom and see that
after that we just have this uh header
here we've got the table and then we've
got our footer so not much left to
go
uh and so that's going to start off
after the div above the closing section
we're going to have an
H5 and this is going to say the and then
we're going to have a span that has a
class of text Violet 500 uh 400
sorry uh complete and then we're going
to have space
package because we are the complete
package and then under that H5 we're
going to have a div that has a class of
flex Flex column
overlow X of scroll a gap of 10 a
maximum width of a custom amount of 800
pixels so we use the square brackets an
MX of order and a width of
full and then within this div we are
going to have our table uh so this is
going to have a class of background
white a text of
slate 700 we're going to say rounded and
text Center then we can open that up and
now inside of here we're going to have
the table head which is going to have a
class of Border
bottom uh border solid border slate
200 uh and then we're going to have a TR
with a class that's just empty and this
is going to contain a th tag that's
empty then we're going to have a th with
a class of wh
space- no wrap our padding of Two and a
padding X of
four and this is going to say candidate
number one and we're going to duplicate
this
uh a couple of times so we're going to
have a candidate
two a candidate three and then the last
one is going to say me except this one
is going to have a background of
violet 700 and a text of
white uh and we're also going to give
this one a padding of four and a padding
X of
eight so if we scroll down we can see
that showing up down there uh that is
all hunky dory underneath the TR well
actually the T head we're going to have
the table
body and this is going to have a TR that
has a class of Border B border solid oh
that needs to say class A Class of
Border B border
solid border
slate 200 close that inside of here
we're going to have a TD that has a
class of border right border solid
border white padding left of four
padding right of eight padding y of four
a font of semi bold and a text of small
and this is going to say
dedication and then we're just going to
have a uh another
TD that contains an icon with a class of
fa solid FX Mark which is a tick mark
and that's going to say text slate
500 uh now we're going to duplicate this
four times and we're going to change the
last one to be a green 500 so if we save
that now we can see that show up so here
we have the dedication row uh and the
last one instead of being a cross should
actually be a check so that it shows a
green tick where the rest of them show
X's
so now what we're going to do is we're
going to just basically duplicate this
TR uh I think it's four times 1 2 three
so we get four in
total the second one is going to
say critical thought it's good to be a a
critical thinker then we're going to
have
interpersonal
skills uh if you don't have these then
I'd aim for a remote worker environment
like myself and then we're going to have
a programming
ability after for the last
one now we're also going to oh actually
we have a problem Houston we have a
problem uh if I noticed that we our
little uh scroll up icon is just looking
a bit funny so that's going to be in the
uh layout component if we just come up
here we want to make sure sure that on
our button here we have a rounded full
but we also have an aspect of
square so that's just going to make that
circular you can't see it down the
bottom but it is there uh so just on
that button make sure you have an aspect
square but now we can close that and
continue what we were doing the other
thing we're going to do on uh these is
just rearrange some of the checks and
colors so in the first one we can see
we've got all X's we can't have them all
having X's so what I'm going to do is
just uh change this one to a
check uh on the next one the middle two
are going to be
checks uh on the third one we're going
to have the first
two as checks in addition to the oh that
was the wrong
one well it doesn't really matter as
long as we get some variety which means
that the last one is going to be the
first and third are going to be
checks so we should be the only one that
has all checks which is exactly what it
is and then what we can do is
say uh I might actually just add into
this TD just
here uh for all of them so we'll select
all of them and we're going to say
white space no wrap and that's just
going to make sure that they don't wrap
around uh and that they do actually
overflow and then we can scroll and then
underneath this table well actually the
div that contains the table we're going
to have a second div and this is going
to have a class that says MX
Auto uh minus Marin top of 12 italic on
a small screen or larger we're going to
hide it cuz it's not relevant and we're
going to going to say opacity of
50 and in here we're going to have a
paragraph that just says uh scroll to
see more and then we're going to have
the Ampersand RAR for the right arrow
and that's just going to have a
little scroll to see more on a small
screen when we do have the Overflow uh
so that people know that that's what the
intention is and then if we go to a
bigger screen it's not actually going to
show there cuz they can just see the
whole table so just a good thing to do
to make sure that people aren't missing
out on seeing all of your amazing
skills finally after the div we're going
to have a another paragraph that just
says class of MX Auto and that's going
to say so why not invest because
everyone should invest in you guys you
guys are
great uh also I noticed the complete
package is not sitting where it's meant
to
uh so we have an MX of Auto well
actually the complete package is missing
a few things to be
honest I obviously jumped way over that
so if we come up to the complete package
that needs to have a class that says
text two extra large small breakpoint
text through extra large we're going to
say font semi bold text Center and
Poppins uh and that's going to resolve
that for us and I'm also just going to
Chuck Poppins in the span
Poppins so now that is looking Primo
extremo so that's it for our main
finally we can come into our footer
component this one's not all too
complicated we're going to start off
with a footer HTML
tag who would have guessed we're going
to give this a class of padding y 20
until we hit a small break point and
then it's going to be padding y 32 a
background of black so it's going to
stand out a border top border solid
border
Violet 950 pretty dark we're going to
give it a flex a flex column a gap of
four until a small then it's going to be
a gap of eight uh and it's going to be a
justify center items
center it's going to make everything
centered then we're going to have a p
that has a class of PX4 py2 background
white text slate 950 and a font of
medium this is going to say
connect uh with me and then we're going
to have the amps sand down arrow so this
one's a Dar uh followed by the
semicolon so I can see that there and
I'm sure you can too on your screen it's
just heading behind my face then we're
going to have a div and this is going to
have a class of flex Flex Co a gap of
four item Center and a justify
Center and here we're going to have a
paragraph tag that has a uh bold unit
this bold unit is going to have a class
of
PR2 and this is going to say email and
then we're going to have
the uh actual email so that's going to
be Samuel or whatever your email is
Samuel o atgmailcom
so we can see that show up down
there and now we're just going to
essentially duplicate this
on uh cuz the second one's going to be a
bit
different so for the second one what
we're going to do is get rid of the
Samuel Oak and I'm going to hit enter
and instead we're actually going to have
an anchor tag that has a class of text
Violet 400 it's also going to have a
target of underscore blank and an hre
equal to whatever the link for the
social media that you're adding is going
to
be in here we're going to have the name
of your GitHub so this one should be
changed to GitHub instead of email
GitHub and in here that's just going to
be
Samuel
Oak uh and then we're going to have
a su tag very cool I know that's for
superscripts and that's going to contain
a span that has a class of text extra
small a scale of
5 and a padding left of
0.5 and in here we going to have an icon
that has a class of fa a solid fa a
arrow up
right uh from Square all those need to
be joined with a H dash we're going to
have a text of extra small and we're
also going to scale this one by 75%
inside of square
parentheses close that off and then we
get a little up arrow is the moral of
the story
there still looking pretty big
though uh and that's cuz I spelled scale
wrong that brings that down to a nice
size and then we're going to just
duplicate this whole paragraph tag
change this one to a
LinkedIn uh and then you know the
LinkedIn might be the same name so that
is all hunky
dory and just like that we have our
whole portfolio we can see The Links at
the bottom light we've just been working
on we have the connect with me section
it's all super responsive we can see
that the different Navigation links work
perfectly uh it just oh there's an issue
that's not supposed to be there so let's
just go to our main come up to the
top uh here is our little button on a
large screen that should have an MR and
the issue with the button is just that
when we set the margin right to Auto
it's already set to Auto so we have to
set the left uh ml to zero should do
what we want it to do and now the button
is indeed where it
is portfolio looks Cash Money the links
are responsive everything is great we
got our little trolls all looks super
professional extremely responsive very
beautiful and effective I challenge you
all to make some changes and if you do
and want to share on show off post it in
the Discord so that everybody can have a
look and you know get feedback and all
that great stuff thank you so much for
watching the tutorial my homies and
homat if you enjoyed the video don't
forget to like And subscribe super
appreciate the support and I'll catch
you guys in the next one
peace are you learning to code but not
sure where to start be sure to check out
these small James webd roadmap for a
whole lot of free beginner resources or
dive straight in with these
videos